I really only curse onstage mainly
because I grew up obsessed with Richard
Pryor the more people that are in the
room the more I tend to curse
let's [ __ ] provide value right the
[ __ ] now too busy for my [ __ ] dick
too busy for my [ __ ] dick [ __ ] you
that's a [ __ ] culture shift you
know I curse a lot on stage and it's
kind of weird
[ __ ] you nerd hurry up dick [ __ ] shut
your [ __ ] mouth god damn it I've
psychoanalyzed this and I could pinch
myself that well at least I only curse
on stage and I don't curse in real life
and that was true you start getting it
to practice on stage and starts slowly
sweeping into your regular life that's
so [ __ ] awesome and I'm giving 3
cents here [ __ ] well hey dick
face that they want [ __ ] things to
happen I think human beings overthink
[ __ ] you're not getting [ __ ] people that
are talking [ __ ] and stop being a dick
there's something to using my piercing
as a filter to filter out people who are
only willing to look at surface level
we're not usually the kind of people I
want to do business with in the first
place I'm a [ __ ] fire